This episode is supported by Skillshare.
Do you ever wonder how your brain stack up
to those around you?
Well, if you are standing tall beside them,
you might be smarter!
Researchers have already uncovered that tall
people are often higher earners - which was
hypothesized to be linked to self-esteem,
social dominance, or discrimination against
shorter people.
However, a 2009 study revealed that taller
children have higher average cognitive test
scores.
Or maybe you are the oldest sibling?
A study of 250,000 Norwegian military personnel
found that the first born had an average IQ
2.3 points higher than younger siblings.
This wasn’t genetically based, but rather
the benefits of full parental attention.
When you were a baby, were your breast or
bottle fed?
A Brazilian study tracked over 3000 babies
to the age of 30.
Researchers found that breastfeeding duration
and amount was positively associated with
IQ, education and income.
Speaking of drinking, alcohol is bad for your
brain, right?
Maybe so, but the intelligent among us are
more drawn to booze.
A study found that intelligent children in
both the UK and US were more likely to grow
up to consume more alcohol.
Similarly, a study that assessed the IQ of
6713 11 year olds and then followed them to
age 42 found the same to be true for drug
use like cannabis, cocaine, amphetamines and
magic mushrooms.
Why would smart people seek substances that
could harm them?
Known as the Savanna-IQ Interaction Hypothesis,
it suggests that more intelligent people have
evolved novel values and preferences.
For example, while the majority of us function
best during the daytime the novel environment
is night time.
Therefore the hypothesis predicts that night
owls are the more intelligent among us, and
an analysis of the National Longitudinal Study
of Adolescent Health confirmed this prediction.
If you find this information worrying, you
are likely...pretty bright.
A sample of 126 undergraduate students found
verbal intelligence was a unique positive
predictor of worry and rumination.
However, people who didn’t worry scored
higher on tests of nonverbal intelligence.
Like daydreaming?
A new study has found that daydreamers may
be more intelligent, suggesting that people
with efficient brains may have too much brain
capacity to stop their minds from wandering.
Lefty?
A study of 96 left handed and 96 right handed
individuals found that lefties scored greater
creativity as well as measures of ‘divergent
thinking’, the ability to generate new ideas
from a single principle.
You have little control over being a lefty
or righty, but if you want to take your intelligence
into your own hands consider a music lesson.
After only 20 days of music training, a study
found that 90% of the preschool aged children
showed improvements in verbal intelligence.
While you are at it, quit smoking.
Unlike other risky behaviours a study of 20,221
18 year old males serving in the Israeli army
found IQ scores are lower in male smokers
than nonsmokers.
Maybe abstinence is key?
A study that assessed 12,000 teens from grade
7-12 found that high schoolers with a higher
IQ are more likely to be a virgin.
A separate survey found this extends into
later years as well.
By age 19, 80% of US males and 75% of females
have lost their virginity and 87% of college
undergraduates have lost their virginity.
However, when assessing elite colleges this
number becomes much lower.
56% of Princeton undergraduates have had sex,
59% at Harvard, and 51% at MIT.
Finally, do you find this picture funny?
Congratulations, your dark sense of humour
is positively associated with intelligence
regardless of age and gender.
It is important to remember correlation doesn't
equal causation, but it is interesting to
investigate the variables related to intellect.
So how many categories did you fit into?
Let us know in the comments, and tell us if
it matches up with your experience of smart
people that you know.
If you want to become smarter than average
you need to check our amazing sponsor for
this video Skillshare.
And they're giving away three months for only
0.99 cents if you sign up in January.
Skillshare is an online community for creators
with over 17 thousand classes in things like
design, photography and even like cooking
classes.
I've personally used it for visual effects
and improving my After Effects skills.
It's been a huge asset for me.
I actually took a writing course.
I'm trying to write different things, like
comedy and sketches.
And this helped me so much.
Anyone can take a class.
You can even teach a class with A premium
membership starting as low as $10/month for
unlimited access.
Head to the link below in the description
and start learning.
Thanks for watching and subscribing and we
will see you all next Thursday for a new science
video.